We were unimpressed with the Slap Chop,...
...the Ab Circle Pro,...
...and the Snuggies.
Will I ever find something on late night TV that Consumer Reports likes?
How about the Ove Glove?
Watch out! That hot dish can slip, causing a big mess.
You need the Ove Glove.
Do I need the Ove Glove?
Let's see how it does in our labs before I fork over 20 bucks for one.
We use the Ove Glove, along with a regular oven mitt and a potholder...
...to take a Dutch oven out of a 540-degree oven...
...and then hold it for 10-15 seconds.
The potholder scorched, the mitt melted,...
...but the Ove Glove came through with no damage.
Now with nonslip silicone grips!
The grips work.
A panelist said cookware was easier to handle with the Ove Glove than with either the mitt or a potholder.
And when we held the Ove Glove over an open flame,...
...it took twice as long to ignite as a regular mitt.
So, it stands up longer to flames, but what about stains?
Well, after testers indulged their inner child,...
...and splashed the Ove Glove with chocolate, tomato sauce and olive oil,...
...they threw it in the wash.
The Ove Glove triumphed again.
It came out of the wash looking pretty good!
Consumer Reports has finally found an infomercial pitch you can feel good about falling for.
We give the Ove Glove a solid thumbs-up!